you are about to watch my live reaction
to the trailer for woman king a work of
historical fiction emphasis on the
fiction but you know this is part of my
member block over on daily wire plus if
you are not a daily wire plus member yet
you're missing out because we do these
sorts of reviews live reactions
exclusive interviews all this kind of
stuff every single day live over there
away from the sensors on certain social
media sites in the member block to
become a member at daily wire plus click
the link in the description below and
now without further ado the lady king
all right let's get to this trailer this
is the trailer for the woman king i have
no idea what channel this is on i don't
know who's in it i don't know what the
story is about we're just getting a cold
reaction to the woman king
an evil is coming
all right we're in africa that threatens
our kingdom
our freedom isn't the white man
it's the evil white but we have a weapon
they are not prepared for
women
[Applause]
that's the weapon
my king the europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop until the whole of
africa is
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh some things
are worth fighting for
don't know
based on true events to join the king's
god
no kingdom in all of africa shares this
privilege
train hard fight harder
you know how you can tell this is
totally fake is when they use the phrase
based on true events
based on
a recollection of a summary of a slight
part of a tweet about a true story
uh if it's a true story that would be
interesting but it's obviously not a
true story because last i checked
african tribes are not exactly known for
their you know 20th century feminism
last i checked most uh
warring bands in africa are not made up
of of ladies and you know the african
men don't show up and say okay ma'am
please teach me how to be a fighter now
that's just absurd they would laugh you
out of the room
i offer you a choice
fight
or we die
that woman fighting that giant
man
to be a warrior you must cure your tears
like the
holidays are freedom
we
okay so no one's gonna see that it you
know it's just political correctness
distilled down into
its almost its purest form i didn't
notice any transgender or lesbians or
anything there though i don't know the
female fighters are probably not wearing
ball gowns and you know going out on
fancy dates with prince charming other
than that it's got everything right
white man evil black people good europe
bad africa good
men weak women strong the women will
save us from the sort of evil men and
you know conquer them so it's got all of
that and generally when movies like this
come out no one goes to see them it
doesn't appear to be to have much of a
relation to a true story if it did they
would have said that instead of based on
some events hey here's the event white
people did go to africa that's the event
all the rest of it is made up but okay
that's going to be our movie the title
is really interesting too this is not a
one-off thing i mean i'm joking about
how the term for a woman king is
actually a queen they do this
intentionally i noticed this in recent
decades you don't hear actresses call
themselves actresses anymore they have
to call themselves actors or female
actors this is a consequence of second
wave feminism which never made its way
to africa but hollywood is going to try
to to colonize africa culturally and
force it down their throats the premise
of second wave feminism was that being a
woman isn't good enough it's not good
enough in and of itself that the
feminine virtues are not good enough so
the only way that women can be good and
virtuous is to pretend that they're men
and to call themselves men and to use
male terms to describe themselves and
now to chop off their genitals and
mutilate their bodies to look like men
is the final consequence of that so
what's a true story the woman king in
the country the kingdom of dahomey
is that a camp is that really the name
the kingdom of dahomey was an important
regional power that had an organized
domestic economy built on conquest and
slave labor a significant international
trade and diplomatic relations with
europeans a centralized administration
taxation systems and organized military
uh notable in the kingdom were
significant artwork and the elaborate
religious practices of the voodon and
the growth of the dahomey coincided with
the growth of the atlantic slave trade
so the way it's posed there is the white
man is coming to conquer us but of
course that's not really how relations
between the europeans and africans began
the white man is going to enslave us
that's not really how slavery began
slavery is still practiced everywhere in
the world other than in the western
world and it had been long before the
westerners ever really got all that
involved in it and kinds of slavery had
existed since the beginning of recorded
history so what really happened is that
the europeans showed up and kind of
commercialized
and globalized a slave trade that was
already existing within africa they
obviously don't want to talk about that
the annual customs of dahomey the main
yearly celebration in the kingdom
involves significant collection and
distribution of gifts tribute religious
ceremonies involving human sacrifice not
great military parades and discussions
by dignitaries about the future kingdom
so this is another thing you mention
here the human sacrifices so much of
colonialism is misunderstood i'll use it
the example on the other side of the
atlantic when cortes showed up to the
aztecs the way it's taught in history
class now is this is terrible the
wonderful avatar pocahontas-like aztecs
were living in peace and harmony with
nature man you know and then mean old
evil colonialist pizarro showed up and
ruined everything no the aztecs were
like the worst people who have ever
lived who were openly worshipping demons
and killing tens of that almost a
hundred thousand people in a four-day
period at the consecration of the temple
of tenochtitlan and then cortes came
over there and said no you have to stop
worshiping demons you have to stop
sacrificing yourselves you have to stop
in some cases for some of the native
american tribes you have to stop eating
people and eating babies that's where
the word cannibal comes from the carob
islanders and you should know god and
you should convert to christianity
that's a good thing that's a gift that
the europeans brought that's not not an
evil of colonialism that's a great good
of colonialism it was documented that
the lack of men likely led the kings of
dahomey to recruit some women into the
army a membership among the mena was
supposed to hold any aggressive
character traits for the purpose of war
and during their membership they were
not allowed to have children or be part
of married life so they were basically
just forced to kind of be like man and
look like men there was also a core of
prostitutes kept for the amazon's use
that's kind of interesting
probably not include that part in the
movie either in summary the woman king
is about a voodoo practicing slave trade
country that sells off so many of its
own men that it has to make women fight
in the military who then get decisively
crushed by the french who are basically
the jv team of europe the end very good
summary a little bit different than the
log line of the trailer we just saw
frankly now that i now that i read the
true story i'm much more interested in
seeing the movie all right that's the
show i hope you enjoyed that riveting
trailer
based on absolutely nothing in history
just a complete woke fantasy in some
studio execs head if you want to get all
of that content live we're talking about
the live reactions to movie trailers
we're talking about the music reviews
we're talking about exclusive interviews
we're talking about spot to fake
headline we've got new segments every
single day away from the sensors on
social media sites you gotta become a
daily wire plus member click the link in
the description below we'll see you over
there
[Music]